فتكو باليابانيه هو وصف من يتغيب عن
المدرسه لمده 30 يوما او اكثر لكن
المتغيبين يسجلون حاضرين عند مثل هذه
المنظمه غير الربحيه بموافقه وزاره
التعليم وبدلا من الدراسه يستمتعون بانشطه
ترفيهيه عند الطلاق انا في الصف الخامس
الابتدائي في مدرستي هناك الكثير من
القواعد لا احب هذه الفكره هنا استمتع
برياضات مفضله
[موسيقى]
حريه ينظر المجتمع الياباني الى من لا
يذهب للمدرسه بعين الازدراء والانسحاب من
المدرسه ليس مقبولا وهكذا يقبل بعضهم على
الانتحار قررت انشاء مكان امن للاطفال
المتغيبين قبل 32 عاما اثر حادث اثار صدمه
انذاك اذ انتحر والد طفل رفض الذهاب
للمدرسه بعد قتلهم لصغير دورنا هنا ان
نهون على الاطفال عبء المشاركه الاجباريه
ونغرس اهميه الحياه مع انشطه تساعدهم على
النمو والتعلم فمعظم من ياتينا يعود الى
المدرسه الثانويه بانتظام فيما
بعد من اسباب التغيب عدم الانسجام مع الصف
سواء من ناحيه التعامل مع الزملاء او
التعرض للتنمر او عدم فهم معطيات الماده
الدراسيه زياده على الظروف العائليه مثل
طلاق الوالدين او تغير نمط المعيشه
المفاجئ او امراض نفسيه كالاكتئاب
الضغط النفسي الكبير للحاق بركب الدراسه
والالتزام والمنافسه مع ضيق الوقت ناهيك
عن التنمر يعرض الطفل للقلق ما يشكل اكبر
اسباب
التغيب طرحت الحكومه برنامجا استباقيا
لطلاب يمكن ان يصبحوا من المتغيبين يتيح
لهم حريه اختيار المواد التي يفضلون
دراستها وامكانيه ساعات الدراسه ويوفر لهم
بيئه تربويه تشجيعيه وهذا يشعرهم بالراحه
ويمكنهم من الحديث عن مخاوفهم
بحريه تسجيل الحضور في هذه المنظمات ليس
له علاقه بمساله نجاح الطالب بالامتحان او
الانتقال للمراحل المتقدمه لذلك
فتحصن فيها ولا بد ان يضم احد اركان
المنظمه صفوفا دراسيه تساعدهم على تدارك
النقص التعليمي رغم الح المطروحه من طرف
الحكومه يرى الخبراء ان اقصر الطرق لحل
ازمه التغيب يتمثل في تسريع تحسين ظروف
عمل المعلمين كي يستطيعوا بناء روابط
وثيقه مع طلبتهم ما يمكنهم من اكتشاف
مشاكلهم في وقت مبكر والتعامل معها مهم
سمورا الجزيره طوكيو